simplify the expression 28 a to the
fourth b to the sixth over
seven a to the ninth b so a good place
to start here is to just try to kind of
break this up into things that we can
simplify a lot easier so the 28 and 7 we
know that 28 is divisible by 7. so let's
say we break that apart into 28 times 28
over 7 times and then we can break this
one apart
a to the fourth
over a to the ninth a to the fourth over
a tonight so times a to the fourth over
a to the ninth i'm just rewriting what
we did here but i'm writing it as a
product of three terms instead of just
one term over here and then finally you
have this last term over here b to the
sixth over b so times
b to the sixth over b and if you
multiplied all this out all the you'd
take the product of the numerators you'd
get that up there you get the product of
the denominators you'd get this right
there the whole reason i did that is
because each of these terms can be
simplified pretty easily this 28 over 7
that's easy 28 divided by 7 is 4.
28 divided by 7 is 4. then we have the a
to the fourth divided by a to the ninth
and when you have an exponent in the
denominator you can subtract it from the
exponent in the numerator we have the
same base a that's why i grouped it this
way so this is going to be equal to a to
the 4 minus 9 power what's 4 minus 9
it's negative 5
4 a to the negative 5 4 minus 9. and the
same thing here with the b's
times b
6 minus you have a 1 here you don't see
the 1 but it's there if you just have a
b that's the same thing as b to the one
power
so b to the sixth divided by b to the
one power is b to the six minus one or b
to the fifth power
and we're done we've simplified the
expression if you don't want a negative
exponent there you could say well this
is the same thing as
four
times
times one over a to the fifth that's the
same
that's the same thing as a to the
negative five these two things are the
exact same thing times b to the fifth
and then this of course would be equal
to
four
b to the fifth
a to the fifth or you could put four b
to the fifth over a to the fifth all of
these are legitimate ways but all of
these are simplified versions of our
original expression